Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm gonna do
another watchman HBO video to follow up
my trailer breakdown. in that I mentioned
some of the callbacks and references to
the original Watchmen comic series and
today I'm gonna take a closer look at
all the things you might have missed in
the trailer. it's jam-packed with Easter
eggs and even though it answered some
questions there's still plenty of
mystery for us to speculate about and if
you're an eagle-eyed fan that's sure
they caught all of the references I'm
about to mention never fear because we
got a lot of new information about the
show at the TCA panel last night so I'll
be getting into all of that as well this
video will contain spoilers from the
source material and I highly recommend
reading the graphic novel before the
show comes out but either way you've now
been warned so let's get down to
business
Watchmen takes place in a reality that
is similar to our own it's timeline
diverges from ours in the late 1930s
when costume adventurers or vigilantes
depending on who you ask hit the scene
I'll talk about the differences as we go
as you see references throughout to
remind us that things are different in
this universe take this airship for
instance it's an advertisement for the
in universe show that we'll talk about
in a bit but it's also a reminder that
air travel has evolved in a different
way
most of the technological advances are
directly related to dr. Manhattan the
only character with actual superpowers
in the story and that leads us into our
list of things you might have missed the
first thing you might have missed is the
number of stars on the flag we get a
glimpse of the official watchman
universe American flag in the cemetery
seen and noticed that the stars are
arranged in a circle if you count them
which I did you'll find there are 51
stars on the flag this is a reference to
the comics and dr. Manhattan's
involvement in winning the war and
Vietnam in the background of this panel
from the first issue we see the headline
that Vietnam has become the 51st state
another interesting flag tidbit is that
we see instances where mobs that we see
clashing with the police are flying the
old flag this could be a symbol that
some people in the Watchmen universe
might be unhappy with changes they feel
are going on in the country around them
and we'll get into more about this in a
minute the next thing you might have
missed is the references to the
presidents in the Watchmen universe and
we got some more details about the
from Lindelof at TCA in The Watchmen
comic Richard Nixon saw to a repeal of
the 22nd amendment limiting presidents
to two terms
he was never exposed for Watergate
possibly because the comedian killed
Woodward and Bernstein and he was still
president in 1985 when the story takes
place according to the showrunner Nixon
won re-election again in 1988 but died
in office leaving his vice President
Gerald Ford in charge in 1992 Robert
Redford defeated Ford and has remained
president to the present day
this is hinted at at the end of the
comic series at the office of the new
frontiersman and we see this poster of
four important presidents in the school
where Angela makes the smiley face with
eggs that of course is a reference to
the comedian's pin that he always wore
and even includes a drop of blood on the
left eye which we see repeated
throughout the comic we do know now that
the Watchmen TV series takes place in
2019 so that means that Nixon and
Redford were the only two u.s.
presidents to occupied the office since
1968 or if you don't feel like doing the
math the last fifty-one years also in
the trailer we see a newspaper article
saying that Redford won't be seeking
another term though there's another
reference to Richard Nixon you might
have missed the trailer park is called
Nixonville and is complete with the
statue of the former president if you
look closely at the statue you can see
that someone has broken one of the
fingers turning his trademark peace sign
into him giving those who enter the
middle finger I seen a few people
writing about the show connect the name
of the trailer park Nixonville to
Hoovervilles which were shanty towns
that popped up during the Great
Depression they were named that after
President Hoover who was blamed for the
dismal conditions at the time the next
thing he might have missed is the squid
illustration in the courtroom scene this
is mostly important because it makes
clear that the ending of the 2009 movie
is off the table
Ozymandias aka Adrian Veidt the
self-proclaimed smartest man in the
world was a costume adventurer who
hatched a plan to bring the US and the
Soviet Union together by staging an
alien attack on New York City the squid
drawing in the scene is nearly identical
to the one from the graphic novel the
Cold War was the same
they're only dr. Manhattan shifted
everything in the US's favor by
being on their side
realizing that nuclear war was
inevitable Ozymandias stages of the
attack in the form of a giant squid
being teleported to the heart of New
York City to divert everyone's attention
to that it works the nuclear war is
avoided but millions of New Yorkers died
during the attack we see more references
to squid on the cover of the newspaper
that is reporting that Adrian Veidt has
officially been declared dead the
article on the right says Boise squid
shower destroys homeless camp kills two
we get a glimpse of a squid shower later
in the trailer and also see that KKK
vandalism has forced the closure of the
Statue of Liberty the wording of the
main headline is suspect saying that
Veidt has been declared dead and since
we see him throughout the trailer it
seems like he's probably not dead at all
in fact it looks like he's living in a
castle complete with at least one
servant and he has a pretty fancy
looking cake with the golden candle on
it we're left to guess if he's hiding
out now has he been hiding out since the
journal was published since the
attack happened or the whole death
announcement is part of a larger scheme
that he's involved with speaking of his
castle and things you might have missed
this shot of him riding past the pirate
flag is a nod to the comic inside the
Watchmen comic named tales of the black
freighter the comics story is weaved
into the main story and you realize by
the end that it's a parallel to
Ozymandias' journey or his story and
the book in The Watchmen universe that
has costume heroes running around pirate
comic books became the most popular
genre rather than superhero comics and
since I'm on the subject of stories
inside stories the next thing you might
have missed is the significance of
American hero story
Minutemen this is one of the things I
loved about the trailer most and I spoke
about it in my trailer breakdown the
main points here are that the in
universe show is based on the in
universe book under the hood written by
Hollis Mason who was the first Nite Owl
the character we see in the Watchmen
trailer is hooded justice the first
costumed adventurer who inspired the
whole trend this supermarket robbery has
taken directly from the book and the
media attention it got played a big role
in the Watchmen universe turning out
like
did you can check out my trailer
breakdown for more information about the
Minutemen story another thing he might
have missed was the comedian and captain
metropolis on the ad for American heroes
story the comedian was the character who
was killed in the beginning of the
original story captain metropolis tried
to get another group like the Minutemen
together called the crime busters with
all the new characters and it didn't
work out he's also said to be the secret
lover of hooded justice from the clip it
looks like the show is a big hit as we
see looking glass watching it at home
the next thing you might have missed is
to call backup him eating his dinner
right out of the can in the comic
Rorschach is seen with his mask rolled
up eating baked beans out of the can and
night out to his apartment we have to
imagine that looking glass is also
eating beans here as well on the topic
of Rorschach I doubt you missed the guys
running around both trailers wearing
masks that resemble his but this is one
of the things we got a lot of info about
from the TCA panel first of all the
Rorschach's called themselves the 7th
cavalry I did a quick search and found
out that this is probably a reference to
the regiment that General Custer
commanded during his last stand at
Little Bighorn
Lindelof mentioned that this gets at one
of the main themes of his series which
is appropriation
he said we understand that we're
appropriating the original Watchmen
characters in this show are
appropriating iconic ideas like the
Rorschach mask he said the idea that the
7th cavalry who seemed to be presenting
a white supremacist ideology in the
pilot have appropriated Rorschach based
on his writings as a white supremacist
Rorschach is dead he's not around to
basically say you got it all wrong he
went on to mention what in 2019 is the
equivalent of the nuclear standoff
between the Americans and the Russians
it's race and the police so it looks
like Rorschach's Journal got out these
guys interpreted in a way that lines up
with their ideology and this is leading
to a lot of the confrontations we see
going down in 2019 inside the Watchmen
universe Lindelof underlined the
conflict saying there's no defeating
white supremacy it's not going away
there are no easy answers and grandiose
solutions he went on to say that this is
not going to play out like your standard
superhero saga on the small or big
screen so white
premise II might grab your attention at
first but he also referenced the police
which is interesting considering that
the main characters are all cops no
matter how you slice it there doesn't
seem to be a lot of purely good guys in
this story which is consistent with the
source material and gets me excited to
think about how things will play out
speaking of the source material the next
big thing you might have missed is that
Jean Smart is actually Silk Spectre to
Lori Blake appears to have taken on her
biological father's name and is
currently working for the FBI part of
the original story is Laurie learning
that her father is the comedian from the
Minutemen who is by all definitions a
pretty awful human being at TCA it was
confirmed that she is playing the Silk
Spectre and it will be interesting to
see how she got from where she was in
the comics to where we meet her in this
trailer
in the original story Silk Spectre -
breaks off her a relationship with dr.
Manhattan and falls in love with Nite
Owl we see a reference to him in this
airship that resembles his iconic craft
Archie what you might have missed here
is the paint job if you look close
you'll notice that it has police painted
on the side this could mean that it's
not the original after all in the
trailer we see chief judd piloting the
craft with pirate jenny my first thought
was that this was revealing that Don
Johnson's character was actually dan
dreiberg / Nite Owl while that is
possible it doesn't really make sense
based on the characters personalities
the Oklahoma accent the fact that he's a
police chief and so on we'll have to
wait and see but in the time since I
made my trailer breakdown my opinion has
shifted farther and farther away from
Crawford being Nite owl himself the
fact that this Archie is a police
vehicle could mean that their standard
issue in universe at this point perhaps
after the events in the graphic novel
the police in New York confiscated the
original or something along those lines
another thing you might have missed is
the name of the cemetery tartarus acres
and that's not a reference to the comics
at all in Greek mythology Tartarus is a
Hell dimension where the worst people of
all go to be tortured for all of
eternity it doesn't really sound like
the kind of place you would want to lay
your loved ones to rest when their life
on this planet is over so it's an
indirect
name to use for sure another thing you
might have missed is what looks like a
meteorite in the background of this shot
I've seen people saying that this could
be dr. Manhattan returning to Earth
based on the sequence of events I'm not
sure that that's the case though since
in the comics he can basically teleport
wherever he wants to go the show could
be using this for dramatic effect but
either way something seems to be falling
from the sky in this shot we do see dr.
Manhattan on Mars and then more
importantly on earth if you look closely
at the news ticker on the screen of him
on Mars it reads man robbed of a
meatball sub at gunpoint 18 year old
wins 200 million Mega Millions jackpot
and reporting live water found on Mars
what dr. Manhattan has been up to for
the past 30 years and why he's walking
down the street on earth now are a
complete mystery I tend to think that
the shot of the paper-mache Manhattan is
a flashback scene because I think the
shot with the soldier is probably of a
young Angela Abraham with her father
support for dr. Manhattan would have
been at its highest around the time of
the Vietnam War and continuing through
the Cold War we can only guess what
people might think of him after he left
the planet and there's still the
business of him not exposing Ozymandias
his plans after the big attack on New
York another thing you might have missed
from the trailer is that Ozy quotes
dr. Manhattan when he says nothing ever
ends this is the last thing he said to
him before he left the shot is also
interesting because behind by we see the
words guila flat which is a reference to
where Jon Osterman was working when he
had the accident that gave him his
superpowers and turned him into dr.
Manhattan
Ozymandias may be trying to bring him
back to earth for something specific and
there's definitely potential for him to
be setting a trap for now we can only
speculate so let me know in the comments
what role you think these two characters
will play in the show a few other things
we learned at TCA are that there will be
nine episodes in Watchmen HBO season 1
and that there will be no internet or
social media in the 2019 Watchmen
universe Lindelof said that the
government shut social media down and
it's implied that the characters won't
be running around with smartphones the
final major thing that came out of TCA
wasn't much of a surprise we learned
that Alan Moore
is against this project and doesn't want
HBO to use his name to make money off of
it but I did think Lindelof channeling
Moore's punk rock spirit was
entertaining and with that I'll wrap
this up let me know what you think did
you catch all these did you catch some
others that I missed what are you
thinking about how are you feeling about
how the story is shaping up what are you
hoping to see in the first episode and
what are you most excited about let me
know in the comments and let me know
what questions are kicking around in
your head about Watchmen season 1 please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't already I'm
all in on the watchman series based on
what we had to go off so I'm gonna be
making a ton of videos throughout the
season this is the type of show that the
corporate channels are gonna jump all
over so any support you can show from my
fan channel is greatly appreciated
that's it for today thanks for watching
I will talk to you soon